pourquoi
[Musique]
j'ai jamais été motivé par l'argent du
football professionnel en vélo à sa
pratique
le québécois médiane des smad a réalisé
son rêve de jouer dans la nfl avec deux
grandes équipes qui auraient porté ni
s'y attend pas mais tout en gardant les
deux pieds sur terre mes parents ça a
été un modèle pour moi n'est pas la
tunisie mon père qui est venu à l'âge de
16 ans je savais qu'une valise qui
dormaient dans les mosquées durant des
années juste pour justement donner un
futur à ses enfants
je vous raconterai les chiffres ils sont
le secteur le plus voyant le temps dont
on sait ça j'ai joué contre un autre
québécois l'aura donc c'était quelque
chose de spécial quand même des premiers
mois gens là un effet c'est contre un
autre québécois en 2018
mehdi décide qu'il voulait passer à
autre chose il a ouvert une école et il
est également conseiller pour les
programmes de football scolaire mais
surtout redonner aux jeunes car il se
souvient comment les loups de l'école
curé antoine labelle l'ont aidé dans un
moment difficile de sa vie
je me rappelle comme ses proches martin
mal pris dans la cafétéria qu on a parlé
de la mort de mon père ça a été des
montants pour moi durant toute ma vie
c'est la raison pourquoi je suis de
retour parce que c'est très important
pour moi de faire la même chose que sur
eux ont fait pour moi
je me rappelle une phrase que je lui dis
à ce moment là c'est parce que tu
arrives dans la vie qui détermine ta vie
ça va être qu'à ce que tu dois faire
avec
puis j'ai c'est dur mais j'ai dit mehdi
célèbes les bons moments que tu as eue
avec ton père garde 400 dans toi puis
maintenant utilisent pour être plus fort
du jour n'ont que sinon le plus heureux
c'est pas de faire un sac sur le terrain
de football mais c'est contient un gène
metex à minuit puis qu'il ya besoin
d'être bien que je suis là pour lui plus
que dans les semaines qui suivirent
aident leurs problèmes s'étaient
déclarés certains définissent une meute
de loups comme un groupe s'unissant pour
protéger chaque membre
et c'est pour ça que mehdi est toujours
un loup robert frosi radio-canada laval